era da tantissimo tempo che non facevo
una reaction ragazzi e questa [ __ ]
reaction va fatta il buon simone
paciello acaa web h ed h o ha fatto una
reaction di haters in italia che la mia
nuova parodia e siccome lui ha fatto
reaction i adesso farò la reaction della
reaction e fermi immagine da dio
all'inizio
e uscito un altra canzone io ha dato
tantissimo e di lorenzo studi ak vj
perché nemmeno una settimana fa è uscita
e inter sia in italia che sta facendo
due metodi sul numero di sul numero ogni
cosa che mi ha colpito particolarmente
voi pensate che lorenzo è realizzato
questa canzone un po di satira di sfottò
in maniera del tutto ironica molti di
voi non sono andati bene a fondo questa
faccenda mi sta spaventando crozza papa
lo ascoltiamo infatti di voi sanno che
lo verso e agisce davvero male ai
commenti degli haters lui si chiude in
casa e piange che si sa che comunque un
commento negativo con sarà stato visto
la faccia di quello stop a te lo schermo
è vero quando un haters mi insulta io
passo di momenti difficili a volte la
notte non dormo abbracciava che c'è una
cura un toccasana per per chi sta male
per gli haters che è stop stoppati vita
di simone paciello e poi quando state
mare riguarda tipo adesso nel testo i
trans in italia sono presenti dei
messaggi
che possono essere ascoltati solo se la
canzone l'appunto viene ascoltata al
contrario ragazzi io vi assicuro che
cosa
aprite bene le orecchie del cervello e
ascoltate ha messo il video e rewind un
ragazzo un uomo merita nelle medaglie
della vita
[Musica]
perché lo regala così addio veramente ai
fermi aia uguale dolore perché lo penso
che la padovana forse i commenti di
diete als in italia e forse a capo di
una setta segreta
aden hanno mai esatta piano
aia sentite hi hi
[Musica]
niente ma che cazzo fatto aule di è
bellissimo il dolore che prova lorenzo e
commenti negativi
va bene dei nostri ecco ecco chi sono
coloro che prenderanno parte a questa
nuova set filati penso perché il rapido
tutti i latini in italia perché dovrei
nascosti stanno all'assist ha
nell'armadio tutti nascosti che si
stanno tenendo alle risate zio penso i
latini
[Musica]
salve mi chiamo capito salvini persone
ascoltate dice salva
avete capito in pericolo lorenzo
dobbiamo aiutarci
sua mamma ma aspetta casa e napoletano
significa a tua madre vi aspetta a casa
lorenzo adesso tu qui latine anche le
nostre genitrici anche e poi perché stai
utilizzando il napoletano ha già perché
rubati datini quindi vi decapitò
spagnoli è questa la verità lorenzo
ma è saltata
la sua incredibile è stufo non ne può
più restare lorenzo dove avete nascosto
lorenzo dove sei lorenzo che non avete
sentito anche non mai non ci credo mai
lega spagnola
sapete che sono andate in spagnolo per
lo traduco subito io non voglio più
io non voglio più cosa non vuoi più
lorenzo cosa sei stanco dove sei perché
utilizzi lo spagnolo per inviare questi
messaggi al mondo perché lorenzo dove
sei lorenzo
[Musica]
simone ai fatti
ma ecco mi sono riaperto le ferite che
mi sono fatto quando sono andato a fare
gli sci con gli applausi mele sono
riaperte perché tu meriti applausi e
sangue dopo questo c'è hai mandato una
canzone a rovescio e ha interpretato del
un genio un genio più note chi era un
must che non so parlare manco l'italiano
io figuriamoci stesso parlare anche lo
spagnolo però va bene e lascio il video
descrizione perché merita la vita
comunque sia trovata anche video letters
in italia trovate tutti un'iscrizione
prendo un attimo per ringraziare voi che
saranno questo video perché credo
abbiate visto tutti ai terzi in italia
sinceramente ragazzi a distanza di 3 4
giorni ha praticamente totalizzato 3
milioni di visualizzazioni del video in
assoluto più di successo che io abbia
mai fatto in meno tempo quindi ragazzi
io vi ringrazio per tutto il supporto
che mi avete dato per eaters in italia
che vi sia piaciuta così tanto e
continuate ad ascoltarla molti di voi mi
hanno effettivamente chiesto se io ho
fatto questa parodia perché
effettivamente non ne posso più degli
haters mai nella vita ma mai nella vita
mi ha pregato un cazzo degli haters
semplicemente mi è venuto fuori un testo
carino che parla degli haters ma se mi
fosse nuti in mente un testo carino che
parlava delle piante l'avrei fatto sulle
piante non è che l'ho fatta contro gli
haters perché non sopporto gli haters il
a te l'ho fatta perché faceva ridere non
che non ne potevo più degli haters e
come dico nella canzone come in realtà
penso che motivo e abbiano capito questa
parodia non è fatta neanche per
allontanare gli haters perché gli haters
parte fatto che ci hanno otto anni serve
per spiegare che in realtà gli haters
che guardano i miei video per commentare
in per per insultare robe del genere
irata alzano le views dei vive quindi mi
rendono più popolare è quello il senso
quindi a quei pochissimi haters ai quali
prevenuto in mente tipo a ma tanto non
ce ne andremo dopo che hai fatto questo
video grazie e chiama anche altri tuoi
amici che ho bisogno di views con che
volevo ringraziare tutti quanti voi per
aver visto dei tassi in italia perché
continuate ad ascoltarla tutti i giorni
è quindi ragazzi spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto ringrazio simone farcelo
per la meravigliosa è a dir poco
reaction
alla mia canzone al contrario cioè se
questo non merita like ragazzi non lo so
se i ragazzi se vi è piaciuto argomento
mi piace anche per i soci che condivido
nella dizione 00 i siti schiette mi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video
spero con simone a questo punto è la
ragazzi
[Musica]
bene